Ubisoft showed off the second paid  expansion for the division which is due  to arrive after the underground  expansion a new trailer for the survival  DLC depicted an agent being overwhelmed  by enemies in the snow before allies  arrived in the nick of time to save him  Ubisoft also announced that all  registered Ubisoft Club players who  owned the division will receive 3  special outfits that are themed around  other Tom Clancy franchises no release  date has been announced for survival but  Ubisoft claim it will introduce a  completely new way of playing the game  underground will arrive on Xbox one and  PC on jun 28 and ps4 on august two  you